discussion but yeah yeah sure okay why
don't we go ahead and get started
welcome to all you stalwarts who are
back for a second presentation today our
speaker is someone that probably most of
you know dr. Holly Jamison who I and
when I introduce our previous speaker I
said even though I had introduced him a
number of times I had to read off the
thing actually Holly I know so well I
don't even need to read off the thing
because actually Holly's one of the
first people I met when I started this
informatics journey I was a I was a
resident and went out to look at the
programs at stanford and ucsf and holly
was a PhD student in informatics at
stanford under Ted short left when he
was at Stanford and and we also can't
hit it off because we're both from
Chicago and both went to University of
Illinois so anyways it just for those of
you who are fellows it shows you that
the people you beat in your fellowship
maybe people that you know for for quite
some time sexy chatting with someone in
the dean's office today who another
person I met on that trip was marked
versi who also I still know as a
longtime friend and colleague and she
actually knows him because she was at
Washington University when because
that's where he went after he finished
at Stanford so it is amazing the
lifelong friendships and relationships
you make anyways but I guess that kind
of plays into big data because it gives
us a lot of data so we're going to hear
today about Big Data which if you
haven't been paying attention has has
become a buzzword but it's more than a
buzz word and it really reflects a major
direction than
it's really not only biomedical
informatics but a lot of fields are
going there's also a lot of societal
implications for all the data were
accumulating and what we do with it so
Holly is going to oh one other thing how
Holly's been even though she's still on
the faculty and actually teaching mostly
through distance but still mentoring a
few of you she's actually been spending
most of her time at NIH and so she's
going to inform us of some of the work
that she's done there and let us know
what's happening in this area so yeah
thanks Bill I I do remember that visit
well even those many years ago and yeah
you're right the fast friendships that
come from these social networking I have
been at NIH halftime for a year now my
main responsibility is working with the
office of social behavior research on
big data issues and what's been
interesting is that the work we're doing
here at ohsu is very very relevant and
at the forefront of the type of data
that they're interested in and that has
to do with why I put the bottom part
monitoring behaviors you know Dan Macy's
who you heard from this morning or
around the noon hour he came to NIH
years ago when Big Data was just
starting he told Francis Collins the
head of NIH and others about what was
happening in genomics proteomics even
imaging he never mentioned at that time
behaviors and this is a whole new area
ripe for discovery so my group the
office of behavioral social science and
NIH they are really interested in making
sure that we capture the attention of
NIH in addressing the increasing
complexities of monitoring behaviors in
the home and environment it I'm going to
try to show you how this is going to be
a really hot next topic
clearly as pill said this is a new
buzzword it's big we all know it and the
it was March of last year that the
federal government just poured a lot of
money into this and every single
organization in the federal government
that deals with data got on board and
even companies as well at NIH we had 28
different initiatives in this area but
there people are developing their skill
sets and in even developing their own
intuitions about what big data means
based on personal experience and it's
always limited people working with large
large genetics data sets issues are 12
the volume how do we reduce the volume
molecular biology they develop their own
issues companies you know most of
computer science people are being drawn
towards Yahoo and google helping them do
better advertising I would like to take
that talent and move it toward health
and especially in some of the new areas
that we're seeing because health
behaviors in the home and environment
really have specific new challenges and
I'll try to describe some of those part
of it is just how do you sample how do
you represent context typically we're
trying to get by with noisy free
ubiquitous data that's available that
describes how people are interacting
with devices or simply activities in the
home and environment and this requires
new analytic techniques healthcare
reform is moving us in the direction of
being more concerned about behaviors in
the home we're moving away from what you
see on the Left episodic reactive care
towards proactive preventive hospital
center to patient center and what's
happening in the home we know that most
of healthcare actually takes place in
the home not in the clinicians office
not in the few times you're in the
hospital but you're making healthcare
decisions especially about chronic
conditions in the home when you're
managing your own health and
well being we're moving from training
and experience based you know Prentiss
ship style training and more and more
evidence on protocols and technology
based decision support becomes more
important interoperable data is always
important but also integrating patients
into the healthcare management is
patients family members and informal
caregivers as well which you'll see as
we go along we know that we're spending
way too much money in the US on
healthcare for poorer outcomes than we
see with others and this is due to a
changing demographic and aging
demographic in many many countries it's
already a crisis the health the health
care expenditures are they've eat up
gradually but certainly everyone's
considering this a crisis the OECD
countries of economic development group
they are now moving towards looking at
health care specifically because it is
sapping up so many of our it's going to
be an economic disaster and probably
more effective than terrorism as
something that we should be really
looking at so in this new world order
what are the issues that are causing the
expenditures it's the chronic conditions
things like obesity and clearly when you
start looking at how how are the dollars
spent the way to address this is by
health management in the home and but as
you start to collect this the the issues
of big data loom large analyzing this
type of data becomes extremely
challenging and we need input from
modelers from computer science and
engineering as well as from people that
are familiar with the health care
domains so the opportunities here are
immense we need scalable low-cost
approaches
for these kinds of home health solutions
it's looking at health behavior change
becomes really important that's not
something that's well addressed by our
standard current medical care system and
to do good health behavior change
requires tailoring understanding the
patient what the activities are at home
and adapting your interventions to
individuals but as you do this and as
you're getting monitoring data from the
home there are a variety of sources this
in itself makes it unique and very
different than many of the people that
are just looking at web clicks just
looking at microarray data or or
something in molecular biology we have
noisy low-cost data from a variety of
sources different reliability different
biases different contexts that have to
be represented and the smarts go into
the algorithms in optimal inference
where your carefully fusing information
from a variety of sources to understand
and individuals activities but again
people haven't looked at this data and
maybe just as one concrete example to
talk about we're now monitoring sleep
quality in the home the data has not
been looked at how sleep has is
affecting other areas like depression
like cognitive impairment we know that
from specific studies where they
carefully monitor sleep that this is an
important factor but it hasn't been
considered previously as a measurable
activity of daily living now this type
of data gives us many new challenges
because of the diversity of it the
complexity its longitudinal goes on and
on and on not just for a short period if
you're doing long-term care and it's
distributed a variety of sensors
with characterizing them in different
ways one of the one of the issues is to
keep this the new approaches low-cost
the sensors are going to be inexpensive
and inherently noisy and one of the
contributions and medical informatics is
more than focusing on the device you're
focusing on the algorithms to interpret
noisy complex data from a variety of
sources and I'm hoping that our field
can really be the ones at the forefront
of making these new discoveries and new
recommendations for approaches to care
here but it really means we need new
statistical approaches and modeling
techniques to address this and I'll and
I'll mention upfront one of my goals at
NIH for this coming year you know I'm
doing a rotation there for two years and
the goal I have is to develop a training
program that helps multidisciplinary
teams work together to solve these kinds
of problems to have shared data sets and
address the barriers that we currently
see in having new people get into the
field and help solve problems with still
having clinical expertise to guide the
questioning so still need new advances
in machine learning data mining but also
I'm just helping people work together on
these issues now companies have always
been interested the financial markets
they are the first out there with a lot
of the algorithms taking in economic
information but there's global
positioning system data that's out there
people can look at purchasing behaviors
computer interactions and social
networks Facebook itself has more than
four billion photos and what are the
opportunities there but the data is all
similar an example of searching
behaviors from Google was able to outdo
the Centers for Disease Control and
looking for
flu outbreaks I'm sure a lot of you have
seen this already you can do this with
looking at purchasing behaviors of
over-the-counter drugs whenever a new
outbreak comes up people are suddenly
buying all the flu or you know cold
medications and a lot of this data is
free and out there and you'll see what I
guess I should interpret this the yellow
line is CDC's data on reports of flu the
blue line or the Google estimate simply
by looking at searches related to flus
and cold symptoms and you'll notice
Google can anticipate in many cases or
at least do as well it's this is a
typical kind of outbreak in periodic in
time and and certainly Google can easily
see you know detect other types of
outbreaks or types of symptoms that
would crop up and even can do it locally
and currently now can we do the same
thing with data in the home where we're
getting data from a lot of different
sources different types of sensors what
we currently have in the home of many
patients with chronic conditions you
know those the typical ones where their
disease management systems or diabetes
asthma and heart failure but there's
also a wellness systems out there with
diet exercise smoking where you're
trying to change health behaviors and
some systems for looking at fall
detection activities for older adults
for safety reasons but in addition
there's many sensors wearable sensors
for for monitoring EEG or EKG on the fly
blood pressure on the fly accelerometers
you probably all have some of these
devices yourself for helping you even
though pedometers you're wearing to
increase your number of steps per day
this kind of data can be can be useful
for
home monitoring but in addition we want
to think about what are the new
behavioral markers and when you know you
heard Dan Macy's this morning talking
about biomarkers and the big issue of
biomarkers and genetic data now if you
add the intelligence derived from
potential new behavioral markers that
are clinically relevant both for
diagnosis but also for monitoring
interventions some of them i'm going to
describe are from Orca tech here as
examples of behaviors that can be
modeled in the home so we'll look at
activity monitoring cognitive monitoring
looking motor speed is a great indicator
of cognitive le indicator of cognitive
decline and also other conditions
perhaps depression just hasn't been
looked at yet suddenly we have the
ability to unobtrusively continuously
monitor walking speeds in the home
simple indicator sleep socialization
physical exercise medication management
depression a variety of topics I'd like
to just give you some examples and the
funding I always should mention comes
from initially NIST and Intel
Alzheimer's Association National
Institutes on Aging and NSF so many of
you have already seen this diagram I
just want to remind you of some of the
sensors that we have in the home from
architect in the upper left or this very
simple radioshack style passive infrared
detectors of motion that are in many of
the rooms here we restrict the field of
view so we can put some in the hallways
and that's what we use very simple cheap
measure of walking speed and you're
getting it continuously several times a
day all the computers have our cognitive
computer games on them as well as
monitoring typing speed linguistic
complexity door switches so we know when
people go in and out is another
Gator of socialization we have skype
webcams and all the computers we get
people to encourage them with coaching
to interact with others
bluetooth-enabled medication dispensers
in many of the homes and now starting
with cameras underneath to detect that
but once you have those images all these
sensors you're getting data streams
coming in to the server a variety of
indicators you'll notice just for
example typing speed for motor which
corresponds with the neuro psych tests
of the finger tap walking speed another
motor test you can combine these over
time and disambiguate true true motor
speed from complications that might be
due to arthritis or or a you know a
particular foot problem compared to the
finger problem and we can get from our
computer games additional measures of
motor speed and then measures of memory
divided attention as you've heard from
Zephie before now given that you can
take the sensor firings the simple
motion sensor firings and infer a layout
of a home by looking at the paths taken
in finding legitimate paths and infer
which is the bedroom which is the
bathroom kitchen also have sensors on
the refrigerator we infer eating
behaviors so that's one way to handle
the big data and simplify the
representation another thing I want to
bring up as a big data technique is data
visualization and how to handle large
amounts of data to develop hypotheses
that you can later test and fuse
information we were using this
particular representation to look at
sleep behavior but meanwhile we needed
to understand what is normal for a
person sleep
you know huge amount of sense or firings
are coming in in this case it's a polar
plot representing midnight at the top
around to noon at the bottom and back
again day one in the center circle and
over a year to the outside so you'll see
this upper quadrant there in green dots
mean they're in the bedroom that's the
sleep time this person has good quality
of sleep little restlessness and time
out of bed in the beginning of the year
and then develops poor quality sleep but
from this kind of plot we can devise our
algorithms for defining what we think is
normal for this person what's normal
onset of sleep normal bedtime and normal
wake time they clearly are in the
kitchen so we know there's normal eating
behaviors breakfast lunch and dinner and
we can tell how often they go out for
socialization this is a data
visualization technique for big data
that helps us take this one type of data
and develop hypotheses and methods for
developing features that might be useful
for in our case we were first looking at
defining sleep quality now for another
person same type of plot but this person
lives in a residential facility where
they go out to the dining room for
breakfast lunch and dinner clearly in
the bathroom they have very normal
pattern but the sleep quality is poor we
can tell from this normal time for going
to bed and waking up but we can develop
an algorithm that will measure sleep
sleep quality that's normal for this
perk and also we can tell what's normal
for safety reasons and what we
communicate to a family member if this
person did not go to breakfast it was
you know did not get out of bed until at
all you might alarm do a soft alarm to a
family member of you know
can use these types of data
visualizations to figure out what the
algorithm should look like for soft
alerts but this is just one type of data
huge amount of data another one another
type of data visualization that's useful
for these data streams is to take our
example of walking speed in the home
remember we had sensors at the top there
in the diagram I had only had three
sometimes we have four depending on the
length of the hallway but in looking at
walking speed data we used a data
visualization technique like this this
is time across the bottom going from
december two thousand seven to two
thousand ten and then velocity the
walking speed on the ordinate and so the
peak of these distributions are the
warmer colors you'll see this person was
walking at about 75 centimeters per
second for a while a little bit less
here had a stroke and then you can see
recovered but never got back to normal
walking speed if we only had better data
that we couldn't match it up with we
might look right here and see was that
another type of stroke or maybe a
transient ischemic attack or something
that what happened here we need we're
taking weekly health reports that we can
link up but need to go back and look at
these types of data because that was a
very similar type of event descriptively
now if we can capture that in real time
and know when to intervene or or send an
alert these types of plots help us in
developing algorithms but we need to
look at many patients to do this right
walking speed is a hallmark of cognitive
decline and is used as a standard neuro
psych test along with the finger tap
with both of them look
motor speed of course neuropsychological
tests are also looking at half test
paper and pencil tests for memory and
planning abilities word recognition now
here we would love to know a single
subjects walking speed over time and be
able to look at the trend this person
received a diagnosis of mild cognitive
impairment right where that arrow is but
you'll see the trend was going down for
you know two years earlier could have
been detected one of the problems with
standard neuropsychological testing is
that people are tested and then compared
to a population and they're tested only
once a year typically and it's very
expensive if you could be taking very
simple data like this as one feature
that you could then use with others to
judge whether somebody was having a
slowing in general of their motor speed
that would indicate cognitive problems
you could detect and test these
potential drugs for dementia and
alzheimers at a much earlier point in
time when they might actually be more
effective or build cognitive reserve
through techniques like we try to do
with cognitive health coaching
socialization is another type of data
that we don't tend to look at in the
home and yet we know socialization
improves cognitive performance it
improves depression outcomes it improves
quality of life and even standard health
outcomes in general but it is not part
of standard medical care currently if it
could be offered as we're trying to do
with our socialization interventions in
a low-cost scalable way we would want to
be able to take socialization data as
another behavioral measure our current
technique is looking at
phone usage not only time on the phone
but number of contacts same for email
amount of email and number of contacts
not including spam if there's an easy
way to filter that out and no skype we
use since all of our people are on skype
we monitor time on video and time on
chat and derive a composite measure as
well as we need to integrate the number
of times out of the home and presume
that as a social encounter a lot of
you'll know a lot of this that I'm
describing it's very indirect we're
making big inferences but and it's noisy
context-dependent might be making
mistakes but we do have a lot of data
it's the beauty of big data is that it's
personal you can look at within-subject
trends and lots of data gives you the
ability to infer an accurate estimate
another one that's looming large on the
frontiers that sleep disorders really
underreported undertreated typically
people are brought into a sleep lab and
one of our PhD students in biomedical
engineering has a son with sleep
disorders and this is a picture of his
son throne kinds of electrodes and
sleeping in an unfamiliar environment
with you can see this is so unnatural
and probably not representative of the
standard sleep very expensive typical
visit to the sleep lab is about two
thousand dollars this student worked on
a sleep apnea detector as a screening
tool in the home just as an example of
how he modeled this put load sensors
under the bed that we've tried a couple
of different types of load sensors but
currently we're measuring sleep quality
just with our motion sensors but some of
the homes
do have these types of load sensors
under each bedpost and with that data
you can measure forces on each one and
actually get breathing rate breathing
signals respiratory rate just by looking
at the center of mass up and down
presuming that the person's lying
vertically in the bed is normal so as
they breathe in and out the center of
mass changes and this is a very slight
signal but you can measure it especially
over time get signals like this that
correspond to the standard sleep lab
signals in the sleep lab the top two
blue lines look at thermal peak flow for
respiration rate the black here that
says load cell is Zach bt's the PhD
student his interpretation of the load
cell center of mass changes to derive
respiration rate and it corresponds
beautifully in the the black bars are
the apneic episodes then they'll have
you know you saw the sensors around the
chest and the abdomen and legs sensors
and with a load cell he can also look
and detect changes in lake movements so
and this is done in the home completely
unobtrusively if you're collecting the
load sensor data from under the bed now
another jumping again what's another
simple simple measurement you can make
in the home that might have value that's
simply computer usage time on the
computer we have a group of subjects
that are average age 85 range from 72
people over 90 but we look at their
computer time over in this case it's a
period of months from 0 to 32 months and
that look at for each individual mean
days on the computer and look
at those that are intact these are
actually population estimates now just
seeing can we separate intact
cognitively intact people from those
with mild cognitive impairment and
people with mild cognitive impairment
are declining in their computer usage
now this isn't a definitive diagnosis
when you slow down or use your computer
yet less but if you what I'm trying to
portray is these are easy to measure
clearly noising context-dependent but if
you take data from an individual you
look at trends and then you also
consider the other types of behavioral
you data that you have that might give
support to this type of diagnosis that
you're after this is brand new types of
behavioral data that have not been
analyzed for a wide variety of potential
clinically important diagnosis early
detection and these might be indicators
that would be useful in interventions as
well now you you've all probably heard
too much about our love of computer
games but I have to bring it up Zephie
does the dude in two-dimensional
blackjack game and he has some beautiful
new results that you'll be hearing about
soon crystal has been working on the
memory game and has a beautiful model of
memory decay and an estimate of memory
buffer length Stuart Hagler has taken
this this last game maybe I'll go into a
little more in depth on that just
because this is a game that is very
similar to a standard neuropsychological
test called trail making trails a makes
you connect one two three four circles
on a page and trails be adds the
additional level of cognitive complexity
of asking you to go from 1 to a 2 2 B 3
to see so you're alternating between
numbers and letters
takes you longer it's that difference
between simple search and the cognitive
additional complexity of set switching
that they use to measure executive
function for a wide variety of
neurological conditions now in our game
and Zippy's worked on all of the games
for years when it was first funded by
the national institute of standards and
technology you give a search string up
at the top and then have asked the
person to click click click in order the
correct letters and then you measure
that time the scoring for these games is
very different from you know scores are
meant to motivate the person get them to
keep playing and have fun what we're
doing in each of these games is
extracting measures of cognitive
processing that are required to complete
the task in the memory game we're
looking for memory indicators in zebys
blackjack game it's a divided attention
indicator here we're looking to
correspond with the standard trail
making tests by modeling individual
components and I'm going to talk later
about for big data what's required do
you just simply do machine learning to
see what happens or do you use
structural modeling to try to figure out
separate out recall from search to move
and then separately from that the
cognitive process so what Stuart Hagler
was able to find in our data using this
kind of modeling technique he compared
our model from the game the extracted
measures no understanding what component
was motor speed what component was
searched and what component was
cognitive to the actual
neuropsychological test score and
remember i talked about trails a just
being one two three four five the search
for the numbers on the page they're down
here each individual person is a
circle taking trails a then there are
scores on trails be of course are longer
but you'll notice it's a nice tight fit
comparing what we can extract from a
game to a computer version of the
standard trail making tests and this
kind of correlation is comparable to
test test reliability doing the test one
right after the other this is phenomenal
completely new but you can imagine it's
another data stream coming in that has
to be analyzed and somehow matched up
with other indicators of cognition
you'll hear about this more from crystal
at some point but the memory estimates
are looking at it really requires a
statistical model understanding chance
behavior of turning over cards in this
type of game and and realizing how many
steps back did you have to go to
correctly remember how long would your
memory have to stay in place to
correctly predict where to turn the
correct card so just instead of in this
case you reduce the complexity of the
data from the probability curve that the
memory is still in place by
characterizing it with just two
parameters of a weibull function which
is a standard way to analyze survival of
memory or survival statistics in general
people's death a factory widget you know
how long is it going to work when will
it break so the examples you've seen
just to review our you know activity
monitoring in the home cognitive
monitoring motor speed getting it from a
wide variety we also have motor
estimates from mouse movements there's a
lot of free data out there but if you're
going to store it all it's the big data
issues loom large and how to combine
these in intelligent way
sleep depression we have some people
working on effect on the phone
linguistic analysis medication
management context-aware reminding
socialization and we also have physical
exercise data now that's data intensive
as well our new project on physical
exercise uses the Kinect camera so we're
having video analysis it's represented
instead of raw video we have this kinect
skeleton representation that we're then
comparing to what's seen from the
physical therapist doing the same
exercises in order to give automated
feedback to the person but that kind of
data we're having lots of trouble
figuring out how to store it well how to
compress it how to make intelligent
flexibility measures from what you see
in the skeleton representation can you
just extract the essence of what you're
seeing instead of carrying the whole
video to the server so there's the issue
of collecting all this big data from the
home and I've just given you examples
that I had handy there's a there's other
you can look at social media people's
networks of friends GPS on your mobile
phone as you go out and about you know
where how many miles are you covering
how far away from home do you get good
indicator of socialization so many
opportunities I've just given you the
ones that I personally have access to
some nice visualizations and giving you
examples of things that are so cheap and
ubiquitous and really an untapped
resource for clinical use but the the
real trick is to close the loop with an
intervention based on this and it's one
of the reasons for collecting this kind
of data and so what what we've been
working on with a health coaching
project and that I'd like to also just
acknowledge that we have a collaboration
with Finland and two visitors here
jana vino and and jose perez macias
visiting from the temporary University
of Technology and we'll be working on
coaching similar to the platform that we
are using here but the the important
issue for health coaching is that you
can't have we can no longer have a
separate system for diabetes another one
for weight management another one you
know if we're going to start working on
sleep are we going to have a another
computer system that doesn't connect to
the electronic health record or is
integrated into a person's approach in
their personal health record so we need
modular approaches that are tailored to
individuals and what we've seen is that
to accomplish this you really have to
have sophisticated user models and
medical informatics approaches have been
really important in moving into this
area in order to generate automatic
messages that a coach can use to handle
a scalable approach to delivering these
types of home interventions this is just
a quick description that of the process
and the the information that we use and
how we use the data that's streaming in
from the home to update a dynamic user
model and taylor action plans as well as
messages to help with just-in-time
encouragement and feedback so the thing
i want to emphasize here is that there's
going to be a coach interface
participant interface and more recently
Steve Williamson has been working on a
needs assessment for a family interface
he's hoping deliver it by mobile phone
and has been doing some background work
in understanding family needs or
informal caregiver needs for being in
the loop in a productive way a
meaningful member of the care team so
we're and one of the big issues what big
data that I should mention is the
how do you involve the correct person at
what point in time the the World Health
Organization just recently commissioned
a report on tasks shifting the the main
issue here when you get a lot of
engineers working on a system like this
they typically want to show the doctor
all the data and and it would overwhelm
someone even if you're only looking at
blood glucose levels for a diabetes
patient no doctor wants to see the whole
thing those measurements are made for
just-in-time care in the home or in this
case for the patient themselves or for
the informal family member that's
helping now even nurse care managers
don't want to see absolutely everything
can't get an alert without just tuning
off and when you have big data say
you're doing fall detection and you're
constantly looking at the accelerometer
and every little signal that's happening
say you're correct for a thousand events
but you make one mistake per day what
are you going to call the ambulance once
a day typically one false positive per
day is way too much even though it's
been an algorithm that's been looking at
a thousand different events throughout
the day the notion of over alerting has
killed the business plan of many
companies that have attempted to go into
this area usability becomes big big
issue and defining how to have a
spectrum of alerts as one approach we've
tried to take and one good reason for
involving informal family caregivers or
friends a network social network in
low-cost early being the front line out
there so the the other thing is that
these kinds of systems need to run for
the long term many research projects go
a couple of weeks we test it and you're
done
but as we know health behavior change
for chronic conditions or lifestyle
conditions are a lifetime we need to
develop interventions that are fun
meaningful have variety they're tailored
they feel like they're helping and make
use of lower cost local personnel that
really understand the notion of task
shifting we find that physicians nurses
typical clinicians have not necessarily
been trained in motivational
interviewing health behavior change
techniques whereas personal coaches get
that training completely but need
standard protocols and need an
understanding or the algorithms need to
know when to alert to a higher level so
a lot of this effort and big data is
about alerting and task shifting and
family members and informal caregivers
can be part of that task shifting so
we've seen these modules I'm just going
to quickly as a reminder just show what
we're currently doing is either
presenting YouTube videos at monitoring
activity from motion sensors but we also
have the interactive connect for
physical exercise sleep modules we have
relaxation YouTube videos music therapy
sleep hygiene recommendations and based
on sleep assessments that move them into
either anxiety therapy or time of day
like do your physical exercise earlier
in the day or the napping you've seen
the socialization participants receive a
weekly message featured news story to
keep it fresh and they have a tailored
action plan the coach sees a different
type of interface but now to step back
and think given these kinds of examples
and what what else you know about data
that's being monitored in the home is
that the connection with clinical
outcomes and diagnosis
for some of these cheap ubiquitous
datatypes has been so unexplored whoever
sees the data first is going to make it
likely to make a big discovery
especially in the area of sleep and
depression and motor speed this type of
data is just really critical for
personalizing interpretation of clinical
events because you need to look at
within-subject trends and not compare
people to a population and variability
in itself is an important indicator and
a feature that you cannot get when you
only take a measurement in a clinicians
office so the implications now are that
in order to handle this we and
understand what behaviors are normal for
an individual requires a lot of you
modeling techniques and data models to
infer patient state we need to be sure
we understand how to model context and
not try to average it out we need
sophisticated user models in order to
tailor the interventions and one thing
we haven't talked about yet or once
you're in the realm of behaviors privacy
and security loom large with genetic
data of course the security and privacy
there are big issues because that
completely defines many of the disease
risks they have but here we're talking
about sleep behaviors what they're doing
throughout the day who do they want to
share the data with it's not absolute
privacy and security but a definition of
an individual's preference for how they
share the data they may want to share
data with a particular family member and
not others they need to share the data
with a coach but what data gets brought
up to the physician so then the other
issue of course for big data is how do
you summarize it and for whom the
physician should see one type of report
a nurse
should see another nurse care manager
should see another a coach and other
family member another and these these
types of that's one reason steve was
doing qualitative early needs assessment
before even starting to build the family
interface and a mobile device because we
need to understand not only what data
but what quantization and what format
works best for them and what timing so
this means there's many challenges here
the data is frequent but noisy and
context dependent when you deal with
behaviors we need to understand the
noise associated with particular sensor
how to integrate data from a variety of
sensors when you're doing data fusion
you might have in one context one
particular variable would be a good
reliable indicator while another would
not so this means we need to be able to
characterize in our data types the
source of the data how it was sampled we
just heard from you know visiting with
some of the Orca tech members about well
what what metadata you need for each
sensor you can need to know about the
battery many of the clock starts slowing
down a lot of things that we don't
anticipate that we've come up with like
25 different characterizations for each
sensor and it's just not well defined
how to best represent the quality of the
data and that's not been a problem for
anybody else working with a very
specific like web clicks or genetic data
this new type of behavioral data is
bringing out many many new issues that
have to be addressed we need to
understand how it's sampled do you do
even sampling or do intelligent sparse
sampling during important times and and
I already mentioned the problem with
alert fatigue and how dangerous it can
be if you don't treat that as an
important priority
now this isn't necessarily a readable
slide I just want to point you to the
gartner report on the hype cycle for big
data that came out in july of last year
they go long from the technology trigger
the peak of inflated expectations the
trough of disillusionment to the slope
of enlightenment and the plateau of
productivity where behavior data sits on
this we don't know but it's it clearly
there's a lot of hype and everybody
wants to be talking about big data and
I'm quite embarrassed to be part of that
but this I do want to make sure the
behavioral data is at least considered
on par with the rest of the data types
that are being considered by NIH now
just as winding up I wanted to give you
a couple of new approaches that have
been out there for data visualization
deb roy gave a TED talk last year where
he monitored his son usage of the word
water where did it occur in the house
and in what contact context and has
video of everything now that's big data
but that's just one little boy in one
family how does that extrapolate but
here's the type of plot he used you know
so that the peaks reflect lots of water
over the year the word being said and
the rest shows a little bit of the
context something like the typical word
plots that you see that's a diagram of
their apartment now another darp is
working on topological analysis of big
data sets where you take a highly
multi-dimensional space and try to
figure out what are what are the
connections where you can use parameters
to summarize and then plot those in and
what relationship do they have and I
can't really explain this approach or
this particular application but what I
do want to
hold on to is that this is a technique
that might be useful as we're exploring
huge multi-dimensional data sets so in
the training that we're trying to
propose what are the techniques that are
required what should people know at
least a little bit about so they know
they can use the appropriate tool for
the problem there's standard statistical
modeling that we're all taught in D mice
and you consider that to be a black box
and that's the typical regression and
you look at associations unsupervised
learning and clustering is also kind of
black box statistical approach even
though it's starting to look towards
machine learning then if you add in
functional equations and invariance and
and add in constraints that you know
about the system you can get stronger
relationships then there's process
models that we need to consider decision
models time series graph model
simulation but all the while typically
people are taught and develop an
expertise in one or two of these and
then they go around looking for
appropriate problems so it's the hammer
looking for the nail what what we're
trying to do in the Big Data training is
give not only the behavioral researchers
and the but also the modelers engineers
computer scientists more of an idea of
what tools are available especially with
data visualization making sure they
understand the data this is really key
with behavioral data you need to
understand what's noise did you did your
data come in correctly what are the
potential biases how do you correct for
it and this is one of my favorite quotes
from John to key that an approximate
answer to the right problem is worth a
lot more than exact answer to an
approximate problem this is a we're all
at risk and academia for
drifting towards problems that are
easily easily measurable and easily
publishable as opposed to stepping back
and figuring out what's the real crux of
the problem here what one good example
is patient utilities and doing a
decision analysis we spend a lot of
money on clinical trials to get the
probabilities just right down to really
well understood prognosis and then have
no information on how to use patient
preferences on the other part of
developing expected utility for making a
high-quality individual decision for a
particular patient and I want to make
sure in the training is we try to help
people look at their data sets make sure
they're asking important questions and
not just doing random machine learning
to see what associations pop up using
structural equation modeling to to
figure out when you do have constraints
that you know how can you best represent
them in the way that we did with some of
the computer games and separating out we
know there's a search phase of recall
phase and a cognitive phase or at least
we're going to try to model it that way
and extract stronger relationships so
the real questions that people that are
starting to move into a new field like
this or what what variables are you
going to include and what model should I
use what features are going to be
important how do I even get started in
defining some features and picking them
anyway I would love to have a discussion
afterwards if anybody's interested in
helping us define what the Big Data
skill sets are in training how did how
to do intelligent data sampling data
visualization you know the things that
we've mentioned here if you can be
thinking about what what tools would you
want to see if you were working in this
new area what you would need training in
the clinical domain and the clinicians
will need training
at least to communicate with the
modelers really to have clinicians
involved and additionally we see in many
institutions people don't have technical
people on staff to help with the data
security and how to represent the data
how to de-identify it appropriately and
then we're hoping to have an
infrastructure or a facility that will
help I arbys in analyzing their projects
as they go through because usually they
can't really make a recommendation or
even approve something intelligently
that comes through with the new mobile
devices for example do they know that
the data is not hackable or that how how
easy it is to lose the security of data
in some of these cases so we need
standard guidelines to help people so
this is my last slide in take-home
messages we know we're shifting to out
of hospital care it's important to get
to the home and we there's certainly a
need for these behavioural metrics and
they can be low-cost and scalable but do
require incredible intelligent
algorithms to make those reasonable
inferences and it just really hasn't
been explored enough and by moving into
this area and getting down and dirty
with it i'm sure you'll be on the
forefront of some important discoveries
so many challenges but i'd like to get
everyone's help here if you have
suggestions and want to participate i'm
happy to to take your suggestions and
questions at this point thanks
there's got to be a suggestion yeah
Michael this is more of a question that
a suggestion but so you know my interest
in this area yes I do from the past but
I had worked on a project at my current
place of employment for the ONC and we
were talking about they were interested
in per patient generated health data and
i think it was Charlie safran made some
comment when we interviewed him which
that there's a difference between
sensing the data and making sense of the
data and in the course of your talk you
talk showed the behavioral data that you
would obviously use to try to change
health behaviors with health culture but
in between there were signs of places
where there were warning signals like
that the the trend downward trend of the
walking speed that the provider for that
patient would want to know about so I'm
just trying to think about how how do
you grab those very important pieces of
data and get them over to the doctor
into the medical record the first step
is that we need to do research to really
see what trends are significant like we
could see the slope of that individual
and we've looked at the slope of
populations of people that have mild
cognitive impairment and populations
that are cognitively intact but those
cognitively intact usually have a mix of
abnormals that will be diagnosed two
years later now the research first needs
to go in to understand what's the
clinical protocol what's a doctor going
to do with it the stage we're in right
now is that we've made all these
measurements and we've shown some
alarming associations like for example
it looked like somebody has stroke
but if you see a sudden downward
movement in the walking speed what kind
of alert are you going to send and where
you're going to tell the doctor we don't
know at this time we're just we have
enough data to say wow this looks
important this looks more diagnostic
than a blood test at this point in time
or or asking somebody on the phone how
you doing where we know there's
information there but the next step is
to define some clinical trials to
associate behavioral data with clinical
outcomes and prove that we have an early
diagnostic measure now one of our
approach is now is to try to if it's a
cognitive indicator to start looking at
hepatitis C patients going on interferon
which changes their cognitive
performance or breast cancer chemo brain
where there's cognitive problems while
they're on chemo and takes a while to
recover and do they ever recover
nobody's you know these once a year
tests are not really going to be as
helpful if we but we first gone in baby
steps prove there's a correspondence
with the standard test and we think we
can do a lot better than the standard
test not only because we're getting
continuous measures but we think we're
extracting even better measures of
performance than somebody sitting in
once a year in an unfamiliar place
taking a test that they might not
understand might have english as a
second language and a variety of other
complicating factors so that's the first
step and then to prove the
correspondence with clinical outcomes
we're not ready to tell physicians what
to do with the data yet not this data
anyway we certainly know what to do with
blood glucose and heart failure data but
most of what they're measuring for heart
failure even wait the symptoms shortness
of breath tiredness
league that's not useful to the doctor
it's for immediate management a nurse
care manager manager can intervene if
there's fluid overload change the dryer
etic but there's the task shifting is a
real important message here the right
person should be getting the data at the
right frequency but not to overload
positions with volumes of data that they
can't act upon that's that's a big
message mill around and give me
suggestions please thanks